artists ruled the night and we had an
exclusive backstage position
to witness history being made but of
course we have to start with the big
one yes the official coronation of the
grammy queen
the one and only beyonce
breaking the all-time record for the
most grammy wins ever by any female
artist
or any singer male or female the grammy
goes to
[Applause]
beyonce
this is so overwhelming i've been
working my whole life
since nine years old and i'm i can't
believe this
happened this is such a magical night
thank you so much blue
she won a grammy tonight i'm so honored
to be your mommy
nine-year-old blue along with her mom
took home best music video for brown
skinned girl
that puts the carter family's total
grammy wins at 52
beyonce had another history making
moment she and megan the stallion
are the first pair of women to win best
rap performance
megan i have so much respect for you and
i'm honored that you asked me to be a
part of the song
it's time baby mega nostalgia
megan who won three of her four
nominations fought back tears accepting
best new artist
i don't want to cry but every artist
that was nominated for this award
is so amazing megan told me she
dedicated the night to her mom
who died of a brain tumor in 2019. what
would she say tonight because she's
watching you
she definitely we'll be in here crying
we will be crying together my makeup
will be terrible but i know she's proud
what is next what is the thing that you
want next hmm i just want us to be able
to
have a really super fun hot girl summer
part two
oh yeah we got a taste of that i don't
cook i don't clean but let me tell you i
got this
ring megan joined cardi b who pole
danced on the heel of a giant stiletto
for the first tv performance of wap
the only category megan lost record of
the year
that went to billy irish
and it feels was a like ago
but billy turned that into a megan
tribute genuinely
this goes to her can we just cheer for
megan stallion please
and after eight grammy wins billy's
brother told me he stores his gold in a
prime spot
i keep him on this shelf in my living
room that's too high for my dog
to knock him over